flutterby light-up fairy
there she goes air storm fire tech bow
snow glow Elsa doll these are just a few
of the toys on Walmart's chosen by kids
list for this holiday shopping season
for the second year Walmart invited
hundreds of kids to Dallas with one
important but fun task play with toys
the kids ranging from 18 months to 12
years then voted on their favorites the
world's largest retailer used to rely on
an army of toy buyers to pick hot
holiday items but with the kids in
charge it discovered what they wanted
creativity and crafting with girls
flocking to the decorate your own mobile
phone case and the Spin Master sewing
machine hot licenses and entertainment
one word frozen and reboots of classics
remember Hot Wheels how about a Hot
Wheels remote controlled flying car
Walmart uses the list to market the toys
as chosen by kids and stores and online
touting them as a way for parents to get
insight into what their tots want
perhaps even more importantly Walmart
uses the list to drive inventory
decisions last year's top seller for
girls was an earlier version of the
flutterby fairy we've never had one in
the marketplace and watching the little
girls play with that item we really
realized we needed to have more to
really satisfy all the girls that were
gonna want it and so this event helped
us really see that in a way that the
buyers sitting at their desk wouldn't
have known that
the end goal which can be a challenging
one the right toy the right price and
the right amount to stock shelves and
fulfill orders